Kobe Bryant's wife Vanessa Bryant has
made her first public move since her
husband and daughter Gianna died on
Sunday tragically in a helicopter crash
the mom of four whose Instagram has long
been private it's now public on the
platform at the same time she changed
her settings she changed her profile
picture to this heartbreaking shot of
Gigi and Kobe embracing one another a
source who was close with the Bryant
family told eats he quote vanessa is
completely shocked and heartbroken but
is trying to stay as strong as she can
in front of her children vanessa married
Kobe when she was 18 and never expected
to live her life without him and that is
going to take time she has been
surrounded by her family and friends but
she feels almost numb to everything she
is thankful for the outpouring of love
she and her family have received and
will respond when she's ready right now
she's taking time to be with her girls
for now
Vanessa's public move is her statement
her timeline is full of pics and videos
of Kobe and their four girls and offers
fans a rare glimpse inside the Bryant
family's personal world
the last photo Vanessa posted of Kobe
was on January 17th a throwback shot of
them together in Rome with their
firstborn Natalya in 2004 here are some
more of Vanessa's sweetest Instagram
moments with Kobe
[Applause]
[Music]
she's amazing
[Music]
the matter actually a video shoot that I
was filming she was there
we actually had when we first met we
have it on tape so we get to show our
kids that's when we first met we caught
it on tape we're just really blessed
very fortunate